one of the hardest questions as a
as uh is why is there suffering in the
world
do you have a good answer well i have i
have some answers
um but you're right that it is one of
the toughest questions
the problem of pain or the problem of
suffering
or the problem of uh theodicy as
as theologians call it is is probably
one of the toughest i think it's
important to
um say that there are certain types of
answers to this question
but there are aspects of this question
to which there is no
intellectual answer that is going to
satisfy
um and and the the fact of the matter is
you know when i'm speaking to an
audience
uh let's say um at some kind of lecture
i can be sure that there are p there are
people in that audience
who are either personally suffering
they've got illness they've got pains
they're
maybe they're facing death or someone in
their family is in similar sorts of
situations so
suffering is a reality and and there is
nothing that i can
say that is going to solve their feeling
of
agony and angst and and
maybe despair um in those types of
situations
there is really only one thing that i
think humans can do
for one another in those kinds of
situations and that is simply to be
there
to be there alongside your friend or
your
or your colleague or or whoever you know
family member or whoever it might be
and that's the only really sense in
which we can give
comfort if we try to give intellectual
solutions to these problems we're going
to be like
like the comforters that were in the
book of job in the
in the bible um who who brought no
comfort
to job himself um with their
intellectual answers
but if they had been there and some of
them were there they sat alongside
that is some level of comfort and after
all
that's the meaning of the word
compassion it means to suffer alongside
of somebody and i would say
first off you know what does a christian
say about suffering
the the first thing a christian should
say is
compassion is all that really counts and
what's more
we say that god has acted
in compassion towards us
that is to say he has suffered with us
in the person of jesus christ and when
we see the passion of jesus
we recognize that god takes
suffering deadly seriously has taken it
so seriously
that he's been willing to come and be a
part of his creation
in the person of of jesus christ and
suffer
death the most horrible death on the
cross
um and for our benefit so that's one
side of
of suffering but the question
you know the philosophical question
remains you know surely if god is good
you know
and god is omnipotent benevolent
you know why doesn't he take away all
the suffering why doesn't he
cause miracles to occur that will take
away all this suffering
i think there are some good answers to
that question um
in the in the following sense that um
you know we live in a world where
the consistency of the world is an
absolutely crucial part of it you know
the fact that
our world behaves reproducibly in the
main
is absolutely essential for the
integrity
of our lives without it we wouldn't
exist
okay and so there is a sense in which
the integrity of creation
um calls for there being consistent
behavior which
you know these days we think of as being
the laws of nature
okay um and so the consistent behavior
of nature is very very important it's
what enables us to be what we are
um and if you're calling upon god in
in in in your critique of why isn't this
benevolent creator you know
fixing things um one answer is
he's fixed things in a certain sense
um to have an integrity in them
um and that integrity is the best
thing it's the way we have our existence
the way we live and move and have our
being and
you know if you want something different
you've got to show
that there is a way in which you could
invent a world
that is better that it has the integrity
that we need to exist
okay and and and to be able to think and
and and love and and be um
but but you were gonna do it better you
know and the atheists think that maybe
they
have got a better idea but if they
thought about it a bit more carefully
they'd realize
no one has put forward a better idea
okay so the so another way
to say that uh i mean is that
suffering is an integral part of this
of um of a consistent
existence so so sort of uh
in the philosophical in a philosophical
sense
the full richness and the beauty of our
experience
would not be as beautiful would not be
as rich
if there was no suffering in the world
is that is that possible
well i think you said two different
things that aren't exactly at least that
aren't exactly the same
one is that suffering is an integral
part of
our experience you know that
might be considered a challenge to
certain types of
christian theology or or even uh jewish
theology in other words
um christians talk about the fall and
talk about
uh adam and eve in the garden and and
have
have a vision of there being some kind
of pers
perception from or perfection from which
we have fallen
and i think there is a perfection from
which we've fallen but i don't think
that perfection is some kind of
physical com perfection in other words i
don't subscribe personally to the view
that some some christians do that there
was some state
um prior to the fall in which death did
not occur
i don't think that that's consistent
with science as we know it
and i and i think that um death
for example has been part of the
biological
world and and the universe as a whole
um from from billions of years ago so
so just to be clear about that um you
know i
i on the other hand i do so
if that's the case then certainly in
that sense at the very least
um suffering or at least death okay is
part of the biological
existence and that probably seems so
completely obvious to somebody who
you know is okay with science whether
they
you know whether they're a scientist or
not well so and i apologize if i'm
interrupting but
it's the obvious reality of of uh our
life today but there's a lot of people i
think it's currently in vogue
i've talked to quite a few folks who
kind of see as the goal of many of our
pursuits as to
extend life indefinitely a sort of uh
you know a dream for many people is to
live forever
uh but in the in the technological world
in the engineering world in the
scientific world i mean that's that's
the big dream
to me it feels like
that's not a dream it's i certainly
would like to live forever
uh like that that's the initial feeling
the instinctual feeling
because you know life is so amazing but
then
if you actually kind of like you've
presented it if you actually
uh lived that kind of life you would
realize that that's actually a step
uh backwards that's a step down from the
experience of this life
in my sense that death is an essential
part of life
uh about the essential part of this
experience
death of all things so the thing the
fact that things end
somehow and the scarcity of things
somehow create the beauty of this
experience that we have yeah
transhumanism doesn't look very
attractive to me
either but it also doesn't look very
feasible
um but that's a whole big
topic that i'm not exactly an expert but
i'll say
but i but you know i've i'm of a certain
age where
my mortality is more pressing or more
obvious to me than it once was okay
um and um and i don't
dread that i don't see that
as in a certain sense even
the enemy okay you're not afraid of
death well
i'm afraid of lots of things in a in a
in a conceptual way but it doesn't keep
me
awake at night okay um
i i'm i think like most people i'm more
afraid of pain than i am of death
so i don't want to put myself forward to
some kind of hero that doesn't
worry about these things that's not true
but i
i do think and then and maybe this is
part of my
christian outlook um that there is
life beyond the grave um
but i don't think that that it's life in
this universe or in this
um certainly not in this body and maybe
not in a certain sense in this mind i
mean you know christian
christian belief in the afterlife is is
that we will be resurrected we will
in a certain sense be with god i don't
know what that means and i don't think
anybody else
really quite knows what that means but
there are lots of ways that
over history people artists and and
and writers and so forth have pictured
it um and these are all perhaps some of
them helpful ways of thinking about it
you